they'd come to see him so when he went
to see them this was the reaction
[Applause]
s
[Music]
congratulations
how did he seem to you really friendly
yeah he seemed really nice
nervous at all do you think
no I didn't think so
and for one Frenchman the British
royalty have really left a mark it's for
the safer come here
the safer of Elizabeth
and the safer of the this of Elizabeth
on either side crowds lined the map
Royals
says of Wales taking time to chat and
thank the fans I'm going to be here
tonight yes I
there's not much sleeping going on
just over 2 000 people have invites a
guest list recast to reflect modern
society
how do you think you'll feel when you're
sat inside the Abbey I do think I will
be looking to wipe backer eye a tear or
or something like that because it is
something that's a you know amazing
experience to be involved in with one
day to go one final rehearsal for the
king and queen consort complete with
robes and regalia
and then to greet their guests the pool
of a royal ceremony bringing together a
who's who of global politics what's been
exciting is to see leaders coming from
the four corners of the world to
celebrate this and for all of our 56
members of the Commonwealth representing
2.5 billion people
there are a lot of views about this
coronation the king and the monarchy but
take a step back and this remains a
hugely significant moment in British
history and one that very few will have
seen before
they've been waiting days for the
coronation but the Kings waited longer
than any other British monarch and his
time has almost come